[Musique]
le supersonique charte fondamentale
construit tant sur tunique lattois avec
des virages démentiel massol elle fait
aux routes pour plus de puissance et
attend d'éviter à 80 marcheurs le
supersonique chaque ronde et mentale
provoque des brûlures au troisième degré
tous les matins mois pierre renard je
vais à la rencontre des petits
producteurs des amoureux de la terre les
passionnés de culture et de travail bien
fait chaque jour je m'efforce de choisir
les plus beaux légumes
et ses légumes et bresse les garde pour
moi et pour vous je vais chercher des
légumes de l'herbe cultivés par des
pauvres ou intoxiquées aux pesticides et
ses légumes les gueuses les boules en
mai souper bruce est pas indifférente
parce que vous n'y connaissez rien en
dessous les soupières renard vous fait
pas la différence parce que vous y
connaissez rien en soute
elle corrige ta vision lorsque tu as vu
baisse avec leurs médias perdent verne
aventures de police des lunettes vont
pulvériser la myopie autant d'opticiens
tant que deuxième paire 3e et 4e
mercure trop le lancement des héros
d'abord parce qu'en même cesser les
juges brutale dans le coeur google
mercure trop mais de lancement des héros
tu sais que ses tripes et cela deviendra
tout truc mercure trop le lancement des
héros jusqu'au centre non un mois plus
de plomb mercure trop le lancement des
héros je suis fraude au goût donc c'est
moche c'est prendre un coup mercure trop
le pansement des héros mercure trouve le
lancement des héros ça va pas servir et
il est mort
[Musique]
les forages de nos régions ou des
produits laitiers a dévoré très calme en
fin de repas à la vitesse de la lumière
lors d'une raclette démentiel jetons
flandre par la présence du fleuve
c'est juste mais en fait dans des
combinaisons infinies les hommages de
nos régions
alors c'est mon frère qui
premier c'était un peu long et en vrai
on n'était pas à l'aise quoi bah c'est
mon frère